hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about the
lecithinase test so lecithinase is an
enzyme you will probably know that
because it ends in ASE ace is always the
suffix for our enzyme names and it is a
type of enzyme known as a phospholipase
so it's a particular type of
phospholipase that breaks down a
substrate known as lecithin lecithin is
a mixture of different kinds of fatty
acids think things like
phosphatidylcholine and pastas it'll
inositol and more that are found in
animal and plant tissues some bacteria
make a lecithinase and they actually use
it as a virulence factor to help them
establish infections and cause disease
so it enables them to break down host
tissues including various tissues in
humans to help them to establish disease
there are a variety of different kinds
of bacteria that produced lecithinase
including Clostridium perfringens
bacillus cereus
Staphylococcus aureus Pseudomonas
aeruginosa and Listeria monocytogenes
Clostridium perfringens is actually
known to have a pretty effective
lecithinase and it is actually called
alpha toxin so if you hear someone
talking about the Clostridium
perfringens out the toxin they're
actually talking about a lecithinase so
the less of the next test is a way to
take a bacterial isolate in a laboratory
that's come from a patient and determine
whether or not it is capable of
producing lecithinase and so might be
one of these types of bacteria and so
the way that it works is you inoculate
bacteria as a streak like the black
streaks shown here on to egg yolk
so this is Audrey that contains egg yolk
egg yolk has a lot of lecithin and so
that's why it's used in this test so
then you you inoculate the auger with
the bacteria incubate for 24 hours and
then it's time to analyze results if you
see precipitation that indicates a
positive reaction so in the drawing here
we have two black streaks that indicate
the streak that the bacteria made on the
plate and if there is no precipitation
that's a negative results but if you
have this zone of precipitation and on
an actual egg yolk agar plate it looks
like a giant kind of white sort of maybe
stringy kind of glob in the augur around
that streak but that precipitate that
white opaque precipitate indicates a
positive result now you might be asking
yourself why does this precipitate
result when lecithinase is present so if
lecithinase is present what is it doing
to cause some kind of precipitation well
when lecithinase breaks unless lecithin
one of the products is a hydrophobic
diglyceride with these kind of long
fatty acid tails and that makes it
insoluble in water so the fact that it's
insoluble in water and this is an
aqueous medium it will precipitate if
you're interested in learning about some
other biochemical tests things like the
catalase test coagulase test oxidase
test DNA's test citrate tests and so
forth I've got a playlist that has
videos on lots of different biochemical
tests that are used in laboratories to
distinguish between different types of
bacteria so feel free to check that out
and thanks for watching biology
professor